guys you're not gonna believe this you
might believe it it's not really that
unbelievable but we are about to go into
pizza hut here
we're gonna go visit brie we're gonna
check out bo but i ordered i just eat
pizza i ordered it online i'm so pumped
up it's weird because when i did it
online so you go to pizza.com but if
you're doing it from your mobile phone
you have to click it'll be under um it's
like the flavor
the flavor pioneers or something and
then you can pick it from there but here
it is
[Music]
um it's under my name
yes
[Music]
there they go there they go the pizza
pizza pizzas oh it's cold
careful that the pasta doesn't have a
lid on it mommy's got the pizzas we also
had to
add on the cookie
quite excited about it oh my gosh i
can't wait to see bo and eat pizza what
a great evening so we made belle a
youtube channel so were you going to
upload us some content
yeah
but you're so thirsty because you've
been running around like a
fool like an absolute fool
so we named it youtube.com basic bow
there's basic bow on instagram basic
bell on facebook and twitter it's basic
bow tweets
you're gonna
tweet my inspiration for bo's character
is a combination of michael buckley
and
and amanda bynes
i got bo a nice little outfit he's gonna
love it he's gonna look
dashing where'd it go
what do i do with it
oh
bo what do you think of your new outfit
what are you gonna do
you will not chew this until we get
photographs
we are going to look really pretty
bo bo trying your new bow tie you got
him a bow oh look it's a ton of badass
whole collection a whole collection
let's try it on let's try it on oh
you're like you like it don't you he's
like oh no you're so fashionable look at
me bo says he's fabulous
look you can't even see him like one
because it's so he's so dark oh baby you
want your new outfit on oh my gosh look
at you you are a lunatic
basic bow can we get yeah we need a
little more light oh there you are
look at you your cute bow tie
which toy do you want to play with i
haven't seen you did you miss me are we
gonna tell secrets okay bo
stay
okay come get it
oh confused
do you want to put this on
oh the right answer is yes
you look bri what do you think i don't
honestly imagine it's amazing uh also
you're gonna look so pretty you're gonna
try that i've seen pizza do you think
beau will try i just need pizza from
pizza huh
well you love it you can't have real
people too he's a black little puppy
okay
it's a little plump for our little piggy
oh
look at you
sorry i didn't do it honey look at him
good baby
oh
come here
look at us just matching up like queens
okay well you're okay oh
come here
he's not so sure about you know he knows
he's supposed to sit when she puts an
outfit on and he sits for his good boy
good boy
no bite
no
no no no no
are you trying to vlog
bro you ready to see digesting pizza
tell me what you think
whoa no touch pop no touch this is for
people
look at this oh my gosh peruvian peppers
pepperoni meatballs
oh my gosh look at you you just want the
pizzas you can't have no pizzas no
pizzas for babies
bo look at you
not for you i'm so sad that they forgot
to put the hot favorite crust on
it's my favorite part
[Music]